hello and welcome to the introductory
video of data science with Python course
offered by simply learn in this video
we'll go over some interesting
information about data science and
Python have you ever been asked by your
stakeholder who your existing customers
are and how do you retain them in this
competitive market or how do you find
new business opportunities how do you
analyze the existing and historical data
to offer some new line of data driven
products and services or build a system
which is highly available and scalable
by analyzing the server logs and
understanding the issue patterns well
data science is the answer for all such
questions data science is a new powerful
approach and a discipline which combines
aspects of statistics mathematics
programming and visual techniques to
turn data into information in semi or
fully automated fashion data scientists
are highly in demand and valued and as a
data scientist it will be your job to
analyze the data and offer solutions and
ideas for improvement in organizations
doesn't it sound exciting python is one
of the most widely used technologies in
this domain it has an extensive library
with built-in modules providing easy
access to system functionalities which
not only improves accessibility but also
provides standardized solutions for
everyday programming challenges apart
from being an open source ecosystem
Python and most of its incredible
libraries are platform independent
Python is part of the winning formula
for productivity software quality and
maintainability for many companies and
because of its flat learning curve it's
one of the leading technologies used
globally so how does the future look for
Python as a tool for data science
according to KD Nuggets 46% of the data
science jobs list Python as a required
skill second only to SQL
according to a survey by the Association
for Computing Machinery or ACM posted on
Java WorldCom Python has surpassed Java
as the top language used to introduce us
students to programming and computer
science the Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency recently awarded three
million dollars to develop data
analytics and data processing libraries
for Python McKinsey and company a
trusted advisor and counselor for many
of the world's most influential
businesses and institutions projects
that by 2018 the demand for data
scientist who know Python may surpass
supply by perhaps sixty percent making
python a must know skill for data
scientist forbes.com mentions that the
demand for Python programmers in big
data related positions increased by
ninety six point nine percent in the
last twelve months
learning data science was never this
much fun before diving into the course
details let's get a glimpse into our
exciting range of learning modules delve
into Python it play with Python learn
the Python way B the Python coder
simply learns data science with Python
course comprises 40 hours of
instructor-led training 24 hours of
e-learning for real-life industry
projects assignments and 3 question sets
comprising 50 questions each to get
certified in data science with python
you'll need to complete any one project
and get them evaluated by the lead
trainer score at least 80% on the online
exam teaching assistant support from the
simply learned staff anytime during the
course and for projects queries can also
be submitted at help and support on WW
simply learn comm or get connected with
the staff on simply talk and live chat
options to requisite for this course is
a fundamental knowledge of Python don't
have it don't worry subscribe to simply
learn Python for beginners course for
free and that's about it go ahead and
begin data science with Python course
and get started with the first lesson
data science overview happy learning
hi I am your host and guide for this
course on data science with Python
offered by simply learn I will take you
through this lesson that gives an
overview of data science through this
lesson you will get to know what data
science is and the skills you need as a
data scientist this will help you
discuss clearly your roles and
responsibilities as a data scientist and
look at various applications of data
science you will also learn how data
science who works with big data to
extract useful information explore data
science as a discipline and understand
how it's shaping the world
this lesson will throw light on the
importance of data science the lesson
will help you learn and understand
Python a popular programming language
used by data scientists the problems it
resolves and how it's an effective and
user-friendly data science tool what is
data science
let's start with some of the common
definitions that's doing the rounds some
say that data science is a powerful new
approach for making discoveries from
data others term it as an automated way
to analyze enormous amounts of data and
extract information from it still others
refer to it as a new discipline which
combines aspects of Statistics
mathematics programming and
visualization to gain insights now that
you have looked at some of its
definitions let's learn more about data
science when domain expertise and
scientific methods are combined with
technology we get data science which
enables one to find solutions for
existing problems
let's look at each of the components of
data science separately the first
component is domain expertise and
scientific methods data scientists
should also be domain experts as they
need to have a passion for data and
discover the right patterns in them
traditionally domain experts like
scientists and statisticians collected
and analyzed data in a laboratory setup
or a controlled environment the data was
then subject to relevant laws or
mathematical and statistical models to
analyze the data set and derive relevant
information from it
for instance they use the models to
calculate the mean median mode standard
deviation and so on of a data set it
helped them test their hypothesis or
create a new one in the next slide we
will see how data science technology has
now made this process faster and more
efficient but before we do that let's
understand the different types of data
analysis an important aspect of data
science data analysis can either be
descriptive where when studies a data
set to explain what happened or be
predictive where one creates a model
based on existing information to predict
the outcome and behavior it can also be
prescriptive where one suggests the
action to be taken in a given situation
using the collected information we now
have access to tools and techniques that
process data and extract the information
we need for instance there are data
processing tools for data wrangling we
have new and flexible programming
languages that are more efficient and
easier to use with the creation of
operating systems that support multiple
OS platforms it's now easier to
integrate systems and process Big Data
application designs and extensive
software libraries helped develop more
robust scalable and data-driven
applications data scientists use these
technologies to build data models and
run them in an automated fashion to
predict the outcome efficiently this is
called machine learning which helps
provide insights into the underlying
data they can also use data science
technology to manipulate data X
tract information from it and use it to
build tools applications and services
but technological skills and domain
expertise alone without the right
mathematical and statistical knowledge
might lead data scientists to find
incorrect patterns and convey the wrong
information now that you have learned
what data science is it will be easier
to understand what a data scientist does
data scientists start with a question or
a business problem then they use data
acquisition to collect data sets from
the real world the process of data
wrangling is implemented with data tools
and modern technologies that include
data cleansing data manipulation data
discovery and data pattern
identification the next step is to
create and train models for machine
learning
they then design mathematical or
statistical models after designing a
data model it's represented using data
visualization techniques the next task
is to prepare a data report after the
report is prepared they finally create
data products and services let us now
look at the various skills that data
scientist should have data scientists
should ask the right questions for which
they need domain expertise the curiosity
to learn and create concepts and the
ability to communicate questions
effectively to domain experts data
scientists should think analytically to
understand the hidden patterns in a data
structure they should wrangle the data
by removing redundant and irrelevant
data collected from various sources
statistical thinking and the ability to
apply mathematical methods are important
traits for a data scientist data should
be visualized with graphics and proper
storytelling to summarize and
communicate the analytical results to
the audience to get these skills they
should follow a distinct road map it's
important they adopt the required tools
and techniques like Python and its
libraries they should build projects
using real-world data sets that include
data gov NYC open data Gapminder and so
on they should also build data-driven
applications for digital services and
they
products
scientists work with different types of
datasets for various purposes now that
big data is generated every second
through different media the role of data
science has become more important so you
need to know what Big Data is and how
you are connected to it to figure out a
way to make it work for you every time
you record your heartbeat through your
phone's biometric sensors post or tweet
on the social network create any blog or
website switch on your phone's GPS
network upload or view an image video or
audio in fact every time you log into
the Internet you are generating data
about yourself your preferences and your
lifestyle big data is a collection of
these and a lot more data that the world
is constantly creating in this age of
the Internet of Things or IOT big data
is a reality and a need big data is
usually referenced by three B's volume
velocity and variety volume refers to
the enormous amount of data generated
from various sources big data is also
characterized by velocity huge amounts
of data flow at a tremendous speed from
different devices sensors and
applications to deal with it an
efficient and timely data processing is
required variety is the third be of big
data because big data can be categorized
into different formats like structured
semi-structured and unstructured
structured data is usually referenced to
as our DBMS data which can be stored and
retrieved easily through sql's
semi structured data are usually in the
form of files like XML JSON documents
and no SQL database text files images
videos or multimedia content are
examples of unstructured data in short
big data is a very large information
database usually stored on distributed
systems or machines popularly referred
to as Hadoop clusters but to be able to
use this database we have to find a way
to extract the right information and
data patterns from it that's where data
science comes in data science helps to
build
driven enterprises
let's go on to see the applications of
data science in different sectors social
network platforms such as Google Yahoo
Facebook and so on collect a lot of data
every day which is why they have some of
the most advanced data centers spread
across the world having data centers all
over the world and not just in the US
help these companies serve their
international customers better and
faster without any network latency they
also help them deal effectively with the
enormous amount of data so what do all
these different sectors do with all this
big data their team of data scientists
to analyze all the raw data with the
help of modern algorithms and data
models to turn it into information they
then use this information to build
digital services data products and
information driven Maps now let's see
how these products and services work
will first look at LinkedIn let's
suppose that you are a data scientist
based in New York City so it's quite
likely that you would want to join a
group or build connections with people
related to data science in New York City
now what LinkedIn does with the help of
data science is that it looks at your
profile your posts and likes the city
you are from the people you are
connected to and the groups you belong
to then it matches all that information
with its own database to provide you
with information that is most relevant
to you this information could be in the
form of news updates that you might be
interested in industry connections or
professional groups that you might want
to get in touch with or even job
postings related to your field and
designation these are all examples of
data services let's now look at
something that we use every day Google's
search engine Google search engine has
the most unique search algorithm which
allows machine learning models to
provide relevant search recommendations
even as the user types in his or her
query this feature is called
autocomplete it is an excellent example
of how powerful machine learning can be
there are several factors that influence
this feature
the first one is query volume Google's
algorithms identify unique and verify
users that search for any particular
keyword on the web based on that it
builds a query volume for instance
Republican debate 2016 Ebola threat CDC
or the center of Disease Control and so
on are some of the most common user
queries another important factor is a
geographical location the algorithms tag
a query with the locations from where it
is generated this makes a query volume
location specific it's a very important
feature because this allows Google to
provide relevant search recommendations
to its user based on his or her location
and then of course the algorithms
consider the actual key words and
phrases that the user types in it takes
up those words and crawls the web
looking for similar instances the
algorithms also try to filter or scrub
out inappropriate content for instance
sexual violent or terrorism related
content hate speeches and legal cases
are scrubbed out from the search
recommendations
but how does data science help you today
even the healthcare industry is
beginning to tap into the various
applications of data science to
understand this let's look at wearable
devices these devices have biometric
sensors and a built-in processor to
gather data from your body when you are
wearing them they transmit this data to
the big data analytics platform via the
IOT gateway ideally the platform
collects hundreds of thousands of data
points and the collected data is
ingested into the system for further
processing the big data analytics
platform applies data models created by
data scientists and extracts the
information that is relevant to you it
sends the information to the engagement
dashboard where you can see how many
steps you want what your heart rate is
over a period of time how good your
sleep was how much calories you burned
and so on knowing such details would
help you to set personal goals for a
healthy lifestyle and reduce overall
health care and insurance costs it would
also help your doctor record your vitals
and diagnose any issue
the finance sector can easily use data
science to help it function more
efficiently suppose a person applies for
a loan the loan manager submits the
application to the enterprise
infrastructure for processing the
analytics platform applies data models
and algorithms and creates an engagement
dashboard for the loan manager the
dashboard which show the applicants
credit report credit history amount if
approved and risks associated with him
or her the loan manager can now easily
take a look at all the relevant
information and decide whether the loan
can be approved or not
governments across different countries
are gradually sharing large datasets
from various domains with the public
this kind of transparency makes the
government seem more trustworthy it
provides the country data that can be
used to prepare itself for different
types of issues like climate change and
disease control
it also helps encourage people to create
their own digital products and services
the US government hosts and maintains
data gov a website that offers
information about the federal government
it provides access to over 195 thousand
datasets across different sectors the US
government has kicked off a number of
strategic initiatives in the field of
data science that includes a u.s.
digital service and open data we have
seen how data science can be applied
across different sectors let's now take
a look at the various challenges that a
data scientist faces in the real world
while dealing with datasets data quality
the quality of data is mostly not up to
the set standards you will usually come
across data that is inconsistent
inaccurate and complete not in the
desirable format and with anomalies
integration data integration with
several enterprise applications and
systems is a complex and painstaking
task unified platform data is
distributed to Hadoop distributed file
system or HDFS from various sources to
ingest process analyze and visualize
huge data sets the size of these Hadoop
clusters can vary from few nodes to
thousand nodes the challenge is to
perform analytics on these large data
sets efficiently and effectively this is
where Python comes into play with its
powerful set of libraries functions
modules packages and extensions
Python can efficiently tackle each stage
of data analytics that includes data
acquisition Python libraries such as
scrappy comes handy here data wrangling
Python data frames are very efficient in
handling large data sets and makes data
wrangling easier with its powerful
functions Explorer matplotlib libraries
are very rich when it comes to data
exploration model scikit-learn
statistical and mathematical functions
to help to build models for machine
learning visualization modern libraries
such as boca creates very intuitive and
interactive visualization
it's huge set of libraries and functions
make big data analytics seem easy and
hence solves a bigger problem Python
applications and programs are portable
and helps them scale out on any big data
platform
Python is an open-source programming
language that lets you work quickly and
integrate systems more effectively now
that we have talked about how the Python
libraries help the different stages of
data analytics let's take a closer look
at these libraries and how they support
different aspects of data science numpy
or numerical Python is the fundamental
package for scientific computing side PI
is the core of scientific computing
libraries and provides many
user-friendly and efficiently designed
numerical routines mat plot live is a
Python 2d plotting library which
produces publication quality figures in
a variety of hardcopy formats and
interactive environments across
platforms scikit-learn is built on numpy
side pie and matplotlib for data mining
and data analysis pandas is a library
providing high-performance easy to use
data structures and data analysis tools
for python all these libraries modules
and packages are open source and hence
using them is convenient and easy
there are numerous factors which
positions Python well and makes it the
tool for data science python is easy to
learn it's a general-purpose
function and object-oriented programming
language as Python is an open source
programming language it is readily
available easy to install and get
started it also has the large presence
of open source community for software
development and support Python and its
tool enjoy multi-platform support
applications developed with PyCon
integrate easily with other enterprise
systems and applications there are a lot
of tools platforms and products in the
market from different vendors as they
offer great support and services Python
and its libraries create unique
combinations for data science because of
all these benefits it's usually popular
among academicians mathematicians
statisticians and technologists
Python is supported by well-established
the data platforms and processing
frameworks that help it analyze data in
a simple and efficient way
enterprise Big Data Platform cloud era
is the pioneer in providing enterprise
ready Hadoop a big data platform and
supports Python Hortonworks is another
Hadoop a big data platform provider and
supports Python MapReduce mat bar is
also committed to Python and provides
the Hadoop Big Data Platform
big data processing framework MapReduce
spark and flink provides very robust and
unique data processing framework and
support Python Java Scala and Python
languages are used for big data
processing framework
let us now quickly recap what we have
learned in the lesson data science is a
discipline which combines aspects of
Statistics mathematics programming and
domain expertise data scientists are
solving bigger problems in public and
private sectors there are a lot of data
sets available for free to apply data
science and turn them into data services
and data products data scientists are
more in demand with the evolution of big
data and fast real-time analytics Python
is a powerful language and a preferred
tool for data science this concludes the
lesson on data science overview in the
next lesson we will discuss data
analytics